hello my name is Bruno Oliveira and
welcome to you to our third episode in
the play games in an antique a series
we're going to talk about some threading
and lifecycle issues that may be may be
tricky so first of all let's start with
ready so when you are using play games
and NDK where you have to realize all
the time is that the UI thread is
different from your game thread so
whenever you're writing your game logic
that's going to be running on the game
thread on the native side and whenever
you do most of the calls of the play
games API you're going to want to do
them from the UI thread on the Java side
so usually one of the patterns that you
can use to manage that difficulty is
just use great methods called post
something something and then those
methods post to the UI thread and then
on the UI thread you actually use the
game helper to make the corresponding
API call so something like this post
amid score which we covered on the last
video you just call that from the native
side and then that pose to the UI thread
how do you call this from the from the
native side well well you can just use
Jay and I but now how do you actually do
the opposite how do you call from dalvik
to native when you come from davek
native all you have to do is declare a
native method in your class and then
implement the the corresponding native
method so for instance here we are
reporting that the sign ian has
succeeded into into the native code when
you write that native method one thing
that you have to look out for is that
you're actually running on the UI thread
even though you've crossed the the
native barrier into native code that
doesn't mean that you're running on the
game thread you're actually running on
the UI thread and if you try if you
start now trying to manipulate your game
objects and game logic there you might
run into very hard to debug issues so
one of the things you can do is just
synchronize at that point however
synchronization may be expensive like if
you have a mutex or a semaphore and so
on and you're going to lock that on
every on every frame that your game is
going to draw you might end up with a
very slow game so one of the year are
very useful patterns we usually see is
you want to do an atomic right
especially when it's a very small data
structure that you just want to like
pass a boolean between threads you can
do is just an anatomic right so in this
case we are using the system Tom extra H
so this is the these these are a few
convenience functions that allow you to
do atomic writes and reads in this case
we are gay
the new state from the from the UI
thread and then writing it atomically to
that static variable called state
because this means that when you when
you try to read it from your game thread
you can just read it because the this
can be called from any thread you can
just read it because instance the
writing is atomic you don't have to
worry about race conditions there so you
get the state based on that so this
means you can actually get the state on
every frame so you don't have to have a
call back saying Yesenia has exceeded or
failed on the native side because in any
event you're you're going to have to
process every frame to do animations and
such so you're already occupying the CPU
on every frame so it doesn't really cost
much more just to read a boolean
variable to see if the user is signed in
or not so you can eliminate some
complications there there that way so
you can call gets an ian state on every
frame without having to write callbacks
or anything so let's talk about the life
cycle of a play games app so back in the
good old days I remember that writing
game was pretty easy because there was
no life cycle is essentially the game
get to get started the game gets played
and then the user stops the game and it
goes back to the operating system so
that was a pretty easy time now with
modern operating systems especially on
mobile devices you have a whole bunch of
call back so you have to pay attention
to so when your game starts you get on
create then you get on start then you
get on resume and then the window for
you get the window focus and then you
get on pause and then you lose the
window focus because of lock screen and
then again on stopped because you know
the user has gone back to the home
screen and then you get on start again
so it's a whole bunch of callbacks some
of them are hierarchical some of them
are not some of them come out of phase
and you have to pay attention to all of
those callbacks to know when you can and
when you cannot render stuff into your
game because sometimes you may even have
a GL surface sometimes you don't have a
GL surface sometimes you should not be
running sometimes you should deallocate
stuff so you have to pay attention to
all of those comics so it's important to
keep track in your native game of
wherein the lifecycle you are regarding
those call back so you have to know
whether or not are you are between on
resume and on pause you have to know
whether or not you have the window focus
you have to know whether or not you have
a surface or you don't have surface and
so on and so forth and now we're going
to talk about how to integrate play
games into that into that flow because
it's very important as well if you're
using play games to know when you can
make play games API calls and when you
cannot
so let's try to simplify this life cycle
a little bit it's not as scary as it
looks so normally this is the basic
Android activity lifecycle get on create
to get on stored and then get on resume
and unpause these events are all they
are all nested within each other so you
have you're always going to get on
resume on the after on start and then
before you get on stop you're going to
get on pause so you can have a variable
that tracks where in that state machine
you are and then of course your game
should only be actively playing between
on resume and on start and then of
course there is an out-of-phase sort of
like state machine which is the window
focus so we know focus can come in and
come out even if it's out of phase with
the other events so you should not
assume that that's going to happen
between your own resume and unpause but
you should assume that that may happen
out of phase with that so you have to
keep track of when you have the window
focus other than that if you're using
OpenGL and you're most likely are if
you're using ndk you also have to keep
track of when the surface gets created
get through sighs and gets destroyed so
that's one more piece one more moving
piece that you have to keep dragged off
so it's only when you have those five
things that you can actually do active
gameplay so here you have a surface you
have focused and the activity is in its
resumed state so how does the the play
games API merge into this so this is
what I have a game played right so how
do you deal with the play games they pay
lifecycle on top of that so fortunately
the play games lifecycle is actually
nested in the indie activities life
cycle so it's not actually as difficult
as you might imagine so we have unsorted
non-stop so between Ansari non-stop
that's when the play games activity
lifecycle actually happens typically
after on start so there is no there is
no way to keep a connection to play
games while your applications not
started so whenever get on stop you
actually lose the connection to play
games and you have to restore it on on
start if you're using game helper or
base game game activity that restoration
is done for you automatically so you
don't have to worry about that but you
have to know that it exists so when it
whenever get the onstart call back
you're not connected to play games and
then you have to wait for the on sending
succeeded or on sign in failed call back
so there is this window of time between
all
start and on signing succeeded where
your activity is started it may even be
resumed or have window focus you may
even have the GL surface but you might
not be connected to play games because
you're waiting for the on setting
succeeded or sending fail callbacks to
be called only after that point are you
actually connected to play games and you
can make API calls and remember that
when you get on stop you get
disconnected from play games so this is
what the lifecycle looks like so just
simplify this a little bit so what
happens what what may go wrong in this
case so suppose that your game is
actually running and then before you get
the on sending succeeded call back you
try to unlock something the user achieve
something very extraordinary and you
want to unlock it and then you might run
into trouble because at that point in
the life cycle the play games API is not
accepting API calls so you're probably
if you if you haven't thought about that
you're going to get a crash and if you
have thought about that and you're
protecting it with an is connected test
what's going to happen is that that
achieving is going to be lost so nobody
wants that so one of the strategies that
some games use is that when you are
between on start and on sending
succeeded you show please wait screen
this is usually not so bad because the
the interval of time between on started
on send the sign-in succeeded is usually
small if the user has already signed in
before it's going to be pretty small if
the user has never seen it before it's
also going to be pretty small because
it's kind of fail quickly so it's very
it's gonna be very it's not going to be
typical for that to take more than say
one or two seconds so it's probably a
good idea to put a please wait screen
between on start and on sandy succeeded
or of course just handle that you know
within the logic of your game so for
instance if every if every level starts
with this intro screen that's going to
last five seconds then you don't need to
put up a white screen because you know
that signing succeed is going to happen
before that that pop up I mean before
that that storyboard scene goes away but
it's nice to have to check for that
anyway once that please rate screen goes
away you know that you can safely do API
calls so that's when you try to unlock
something so this is one of the very
useful patterns in that sense so
actually the the actual implementations
of course up to your game you can do you
can do something very smart or you can
do something much more simplistic just
like putting a please wait screen but
the important things to notice that you
have this life cycle issue and you
should be at the end
in order not to make any API calls when
you shouldn't and I guess that's pretty
much all there is to to the life cycle
thank you very much for for watching and
we hope you do you make great games